[Music]
hey everybody this is Tracy in heaven of
the podcast another round with heaven
and Tracy and we are here with mr.
Marcus Samuelsson of Red Rooster
restaurant in pilot world renowned show
I'm excited here
I can find beautiful things on this
table our chicken ah yeah got some
cornbread and we're gonna do my cocktail
yes chef yes chef
whatever I give you guys you just have
to say yes yeah okay all right hello
nurse so you got the mint all right
you help say yes yes yes should have ICP
oh my yes yes what would my drunk uncle
he would drink at the O do this well you
know that well much better we got a
little bit of vodka
okay got some honey just to make it
sweet then we got pineapple juice like
that oh my god you know I'm in all right
is that they said what's that put your
finger was that was that I'm gonna add
in the lemon juice a little pear pear I
don't know I don't know anything
Oh ginger mm-hmm am i hiding I love that
you definitely back you're definitely
back I'm out I'm out to you I'm not
doing the bear bear so y'all know what
this is because yo-yo PME what's that I
don't know what that is that's beverage
I don't remember inna just wrote it just
a little bit no no no no no no no yes
yes yes yes chef yes chef
you know what and then we gotta stir it
up adding some more mint you were gonna
mix okay okay I know my limits hectic
and you didn't work the wagon good then
we're gonna just gonna do like uncle at
the family reunion you're a hard man to
work for me yes yes yeah good job as a
bucket yeah out of the bucket oh you're
not too blue
no and I don't even like rocket mmm oh
oh that's your yes chef Thank You chef
and I'm just gonna sip wanna yes chef
eat some corn bread have some pride cold
fried chicken I'm not
mmm chicken and yasha ears so being from
sweet and use me Swedish how do i holla
tell nobody in Sweden what do I say what
do I do well you say like hey sneaking
and I never lie he will be like what
it's like very cute and he goes I got my
hair today anything so yeah absolutely
hey hey hey sneaking yes absolutely so
if we want to find the recipe for this
delightful drink and all of these
marvellous foods the Red Rooster
cookbook and you know what it's just a
love letter to Harlem mmm into your
taste buds yeah
max yes damn hey yes yeah yes yeah oh